if you ever meet if you if you ever see
me and realize just run run as fast as
you possibly can because if you ever
meet me you might think it will be fun
exciting pleasantly not in that way
forget about okay my biggest secret
my biggest fear that no one would ever
know is we all I'm just kind of awkward
they were just going to be painful it's
just going to be painful for the both of
us okay so it's better if you just
pretend that you didn't see me all right
just don't make eye contact do not make
eye contact with me it's not a
superiority thing it's just to save us
both the pain you might think haha he's
exaggerating I'm so awkward today we're
going to examine PewDiePie in public a
rare specimen that isn't seen very often
sorry can I borrow these um but anyways
so the thing about PewDiePie was he was
incredibly awkward I like to think of
myself as kind of a
[Music]
I don't know if he was just tired or
what but I guess I just had this
impression by his videos that he was a
really funny like really crazy person
and real help I can't watch it
wait we me I'm awkward what are you
talking about not funny you I wasn't
funny enough sorry sorry what but he was
just really mellow and chill which I
guess was okay but it was just kind of
awkward and so I got really lucky at
VidCon everybody I'm cool okay
like I'm really cool I've always been
really cool
that's the pewdiepie brand that everyone
subscribes to tell come on a Nazi why do
you never [ __ ] tell them what I need
to why are you here why are you here
alright let's see what he said about the
other people he meant kind of like
stories with an animation in the
background and he's super funny and oh
oh
Susie it's super funny Oh smooth he's
super funny hear that he's super big
like look how tiny my girlfriend and I
look next to him I didn't realize he was
such a big guy but yeah Batali was super
super cool I love that guy oh we Cali
super cool but rude bye oh no okay we
got a chick more I'm sure I'm sure
I'm sure that's it the one time thing
how are you how's it going yes me my
love cheeks nice is a negative okay it
can sound like it's a believed it was
crazy can I hide you sure excuse me like
yes look how cool Island
now I'm Jenny cuz I can look how
comfortable I got Thomas
yeah being here media media oh yeah I'm
cool okay
I'm hit I'm down whatever okay I don't
care let's look at some more public
encounters look at me here doing a
speech I do something else so I really
want to make sure that every video
upload is entertaining so I could take
anywhere good one Felix you know that it
wants every video to be entertaining and
he's doing two videos every day yeah
I'm also trying to do something
different there are a lot of people
doing the same thing I try to play games
that aren't that popular like sumit or
dreams and on how to say yeah what up
its your boy PewDiePie about your head
tell you all by YouTube and gaming this
is how you get big you play Minecraft
and [ __ ] there's no one there am I just
alone I'm alone in there there's no one
there Who am I talking to at home too
extreme you're older the string I mean
yellow simple oh my god shoot me in the
head place its there a gun I always have
a gun nearby I can't be the only one
that could've shot your pass out all
right oooh oh it's so quiet
yeah oh god oh oh my god yeah yeah oh oh
yeah I was in Swedish television once oh
no this is when I had 30 million viewers
a month that's cute Felix 30 million
alright so that was pretty much it for
today like and favorite if you enjoyed
and I'll see you tomorrow breath
aha oh god what is wrong with you what
is wrong with you ah Dreamhack 2012 2012
the year when I was like yeah I'll do
that
you want me to go to Spain and talk
about things yeah through that damn it
you want to go on stage and play games
yeah I'll do that
that's a great idea so basically I just
knew I was going on to Dreamhack I
didn't know I was going on stage so they
were like and it's gone stage and
entertaining these people all right
you're going fine if you got to go on
stage you should have something prepared
okay I don't know who you are or what
you do
just prepare [ __ ] something I had
nothing prepared am i singing I'm
singing why would anyone watch this nice
get relay lively I was like hey maybe
it's less awkward if I bring someone
else onstage walking fast faces pass
them and hold down today what I say who
do you paint this is torture
ah that that s over there all right
viv they're almost to be another Chanel
well hey Hart you don't understand how
much this pains me I'm sweating I'm
sweating like swimming pools okay I
played happy wheels
I played happy wheels I live live happy
with others I've enough what oh god the
cringe their friend oh there's more
times where I decided I was a good idea
to go outside but the more I see it the
more I realized it was a bad idea
in this video I thought it would be
funny to go outside to bro fits people
[Applause]
all right that one still hurts that one
still hurts
I remember how awkward and painful this
used to be for me compared to this
[ __ ] video I think I think it's
because there's a difference between me
and PewDiePie and unless I am into the
PewDiePie character I just can't do
certain things like it's like a stupid
stupid [ __ ] comparison but like a you
put on your Superman suit or whatever
all right it's different so a lot of
people are like oh well you see you're
awkward but you go outside and you do
all these things like what how could you
do that it's different it's different
you you enter a character it's like an
act I'm like an actor why did I wave at
a [ __ ] painting what's wrong with you
well I know I know who waves that a
painting goes man Robert you hit oh my
god every time what is wrong with me I'm
not coming out for this man I'm not
supposed to be in this position you
don't understand I'm just some [ __ ]
random swedish nerd that someone
happened to be the biggest youtuber
it was never supposed to happen the time
time went wrong somehow someone
travelled back in time and they [ __ ]
something up because I'm clearly not
supposed to be here
guy isn't he divine oh yeah remember
this -
I was like I can't hear you oh man so
they have it if you ever see me uh you
know no offense I want to meet you but
just go the other way okay
just scream how not good not good they
like if you enjoyed this video I hope it
was educational and I hope you take it
seriously
some and every goddamn word of it taking
away but I don't know what what why not
so Monday Chris Thomas find you
dialing I'll be coming for your love
okay God take our me ah steak ha
okay
[Applause]